we'll go back to another viewer
submitted question and this is from
wicked West films nice name by the way
what advice would you give to a writer
to make their stories stronger with more
depth and meaning well we kind of just
talked about meaning a little bit and
yeah well I mean it's gonna sound kind
of facile but it's kind of like these
seven elements to really understand and
explore each of them try to like hit
each of those is what makes to me makes
things powerful like when you make sure
that what you're writing is a punishing
problem it is relatable universally
relatable situation for your characters
there is something original something
believable the stakes are life-altering
for the characters all of that is what
makes something powerful you also also
want to be entertaining and it's gonna
mean something to people if you're
exploring something that is not just
your surface story plot but is something
that has some depth for the characters
it's like if the characters feel
something deeply and are going something
going through something that the
audience connects with emotionally and
feels like they become bonded like we
talked about with the character where
they feel like it's happening to me you
know what they're going through I feel
like I'm experiencing it that's what
really gives it a powerful impact so but
all of these elements of story are all
ways in which you achieve that because
like the bigger the problem is the more
important it is to solve the more of the
characters under kind of siege trying to
solve it the more you're gonna have a
better chance at the audience connecting
that way so so much of it has to do with
your choice of idea and the kind of the
genre that it's in and what your basic
premise of your story is to make sure
that it's going to have the ability to
have that powerful impact so the save
the cat moment or this relatability does
this have to happen in the middle toward
the end in the beginning I mean even in
the sharp objects there's just a moment
where amy adams stops for a gentleman
who's about to cross and they had this
quick exchange and she gestures for him
till i go ahead and he says kind of like
no you go ahead and then she nods she's
not like stubborn about it or no no go
go she's like and you you see okay I
trust her I like her in that moment but
then there's a lot of things that happen
that where you're like mm not quite
quite sure about this person but that
little moment right there and that
happens fairly soon makes her relatable
I think it does help classically in the
beginning if the character if you're all
about making the character be someone
that the audience can connect with in
the very opening pages so that that can
have to do with them being a nice person
like that but it can also have to do
with them having problems that we can
instantly relate to and feel something
about so even if they're not that nice
like in eighth grade she's not
necessarily so nice but she's going
through such just terrible problems that
most people can relate to you can't help
but start to get emotionally connected
so to me it's that it's a combination of
likability and the problems the less
likeable they are the more immediate
obvious and big the problems need to be
for the audience to have something to
grasp on to emotionally I think when in
doubt it's good to also be likable but
there are certainly some stories that
succeed with characters that aren't
necessarily classically likeable mmm but
I would say it can be very
counterproductive if you're if your
character starts the movie kind of a
jerk because you're trying to arc them
into a nicer person at the end if they
don't have really massive problems
they're facing that make us relate
despite them being a jerk it can be hard
for the audience to want to engage and
stay with in my opinion a character
that's just kind of really unlikable
it's it's rare that that can work I'm
not saying never but it's rare and I do
see a lot of scripts where that's the
the the choice the writer made to make
the character unlikable in the beginning
because they're so focused on character
arc but it can undermine the story if
they're so unlikable that we have no
reason as an audience to really want to
stay with them it's not as easy to get
an audience to want us to join you on
that character's journey as you might
think you kind of have to make them want
to I think so so establish that fairly
early I think yeah interesting okay okay
because those kind of those first few
the first impressions count
yes interesting
you